Rob wle is here he's a Dreamboat what a
dream what a hilarious Dreamboat of a
man we'll get to him in one second he
makes me LOL real quick because I want
to make you LOL in your town do you live
in Eerie pennslvania what a coincidence
I'm going to be at the Warner Theater
June 28th 2024 with all new material
pedaling my Wares and then I'm going to
head on over to Las Vegas July 6th in
2024 to the Mirage Theater right after
America's birthday then I'm gonna head
up to Edmonton Alberta Canada to The
Great Outdoors Comedy Festival on July
17th with Bert ker I have a new special
out it is on of.tv this is only fan
streaming TV service where all the
uncensored comedy is where the cool kids
are now so just go to
of.tv Whitney you'll see my special
mouthy and then the two roasts that we
made for only fans that are
wild now enjoy America's Uncle Rob rigle
the legend Rob rle is here well thank
you for getting the introduction right I
am obsessed with you thank you I wish
right back at youo by the way oh thank
you I I still brag about when we did the
ball drop together okay let's clarify
that well the what I mean the ball drop
I got in trouble I thought we all we
were all gassed up a little bit uh uh
but other people got in more trouble so
we we were cover was for NBC I think so
and I think it was like it was a while
ago it was like 2016 or something NBC's
New Year's Eve for whatever reason Time
Square ball drop folks let's have a
bunch of comedians live and feed them
alcohol to feed because Jello they just
kept handing it to me I was like is this
the coke I ordered nope that was the
cocaine someone else ordered I just
remember Nene Leaks and I getting in a
weird fight oh I don't remember that
yeah because she had like a a change
like she for every commercial break or
something there was like a new mink coat
or something and I made a joke about it
and she's not the person to piss off I
guess one of the yeah Atlanta housewives
New York Housewives is fine but Atlanta
are you insane am I insane so I remember
that being kind of tricky I you
navigated it well cuz I didn't I didn't
even know so you navigated well you were
wasted so yeah I can't that um but yeah
like I feel like I get to see you when
we do like weird money grab game
shows Match Game yes a lot of all of the
reboots y God all of those kind of
things is when I get see there's a lot
of good ones out there though a lot of
really good ones a lot of really fun
ones the ones I grew up with yeah right
so that's why I was that's why when they
said do you want I was like yeah yeah
and I'm sure so my my kids or whoever
they're like whatever Dad I'm like you
it's a match game I'm screaming at them
I yeah and then it's like with Alec B
Alec Balwin doesn't do I don't know
doesn't do it anymore I don't think he
does guess we dodged a bullet on that
one
but yikes
sorry um okay so your podcast uh
wriggles picks is out yes it's out still
popping still cracking electrified and
and first guest Travis Kelce stop yeah
okay this is a sports can I call a
sports podcast it's it's it's a there's
Sports talked about yes okay but it's
not a sports I'm in the market for a
sport and I'm in the market for a team
I'm about to have a son and I feel like
I need help should Travis Kelce be my
guy that feels a little obvious this
this is Kismet this is wonderful this I
need so glad I came into your life today
here's why welcome welcome to the Kansas
City Chiefs okay but am I if I wear CH I
come from DC where every I can't I can't
display any of my family photos from my
childhood cuz I'm wearing a red skin
sweatshirt in if that resurfaces on of
Facebook page my life is over and now
you're telling me I need to wear you
can't be held accountable for that as a
child that is you are free of any burden
there I I do have red makeup on and I am
going is that bad that's well that's
what it was back then I'm sorry that's
what it was really was I refuse to say
commanders I'd rather get cancelled so I
go to the chief so I'm so my floor my
college team is seminal my NFL team is
the Chiefs you really love the Native
American Vibe I mean it's like just how
it is I'll say this I've been a lifelong
Chief I grew up in Kansas City I'm from
Kansas City so long long suffering long
suffering been a fun couple years huh
but now it's our time and so now is the
time to get on the bandwagon okay
because we have a wonderful quarterback
who's young and healthy and we've got
this great team full of you know future
Hall of Famers Travis Kelce being one of
them so can I ask you a question about
Travis Kel sure what's why is what makes
him so good I just I love the besides
the fact that he's incredibly handsome
uh are you talking about on the football
field or
in the football field on the football
field what makes him so good is he is a
big athletic tight end and in that
position the tight end position usually
you get big guys but they're not
athletic as in fast as in fast as in
able to catch as in able to cut and move
okay so he brings this wonderful dynamic
because usually the person that covers a
tight end is a linebacker not a
defensive back sure so he can outplay
most of the linebackers in the league so
he gets open a lot and Patrick finds him
would you say he's the art mon of his
[Music]
day better I say better but I love I
love the pull I love the PO I just
remember from the 80s Redskin I remember
growing up in DC and my dad just yelling
at the screen fucking art monk yelling
at him so that's that's my late my most
recent uh football poll but welcome to
the Chiefs we got plenty of room on the
B and listen no so Paul rdd mhm Jason
sedus M Eric Stone Street okay Dave
Kenner Heidi Gardner and myself all
Kansas City we're all from Kansas this
will help me in Hollywood I'm in and
Brad Pit so come on now get on that
bandw okay I'm in sold that's all I
needed to hear yes we got one more but
what about um baseball is that do I have
to be a Kansas City baseball fan also no
that now you're open to do whatever I I
here's what I do I I would like teams to
draft me as a fan as they should and
I'm taking pictures I no pun intended I
assume uh but yes I what I do is I'm
since I'm Kansas City like died in the
wool you yeah died in the wool isn't
that what they say I don't think so I've
never heard that I think it's it's died
died in the died in the wool Pat looking
it up it sounds right I was trying to
have a serious conversation with someone
yesterday and it was kind of tense um
with a romantic part partner partner see
now I'm in Kansas City partner it's it's
being changed in front of you the
metamorphosis is happening and I said
look I just feel like it's like there's
an elephant in the living room about
this wait what is it there's an elephant
in the room not living room it's too
specific what room do you think an
elephant would fit in any room you're in
there would be the elephant in the room
see that's the that's the phrase what's
the elephant in the room meaning cuz we
were in the kitchen we're in the bedroom
it's in the elephant fit in any other
room in your house besides the living
room I mean you have some pretty serious
residuals maybe yeah there I've seen
houses
okay I
mean he was like the living room I was
like it's so specific that's the only
problem you got it right the elephant in
the living room it's the elephant in the
room ah God you know that I used to say
the best thing since life's bread I
thought it was lifes
spread finally at like like two years
ago someone finally corrected me like oh
I I was singing Manfred man's wrapped up
like a
douche probably until I was in my mid
30s I thought it was Chester drawers
until a couple days
ago so yeah and there's people who still
are just they' drilled down and you know
oh here's the other one for all
intensive purposes for all intense and
purposes I think intensive purposes is
better change it I think I I change it
for all intense and purposes is kind of
redundant intense but intensive for all
intensive this is ensive purpose well
and there's a flow to it it just it kind
of slides right in slides into the Gap
beautifully yeah I'll back your play
anyway so so died in the wool what did
we get I texted it to you it's it's real
for real okay died in the wool I'm a
died in the wolf Chiefs fan you're right
died in the wool if someone's uh if
someone has died oh but it's D ye D I
was confused it or has died in the wool
opinions they hold those opinions
strongly and will not change them it's
like the Dy has been cast it's the died
in the wo see that's this is why I have
the tsms because I was like I went died
it like suffocating in Wool yeah no it's
the color I'm I'm red through and
through died in the got it okay sorry
Chiefs fan got it it's been a pleasure
having you on the show this has been
great I feel like this has been a great
episode covered a
lot I will say so I wherever City I live
in I always adopt one team so I can I
can get into it sure so when I was in
New York for 10 years it was the Knicks
it was all about the Knicks right yep uh
but I'll never give up on my teams so if
the Royals play the Angels F the Angels
if the Royals play the Dodgers F the
Dodgers cuz I'm a I'm a KC guy so but
other than that I'll root for the the
Dodgers I have no problem could you ever
have a romantic relationship with
someone that roots for the Oppo like
who's the CH the Raiders a Raiders fan
you couldn't do it
no you could if this woman was the one
the one soulmate soulmate and an angel
actually came down fromto wiggle yeah
and literally whispered on my ear this
is a special one for you yeah and just
you and then you you madly in love and
for whatever reason you'd never seen the
nape of her neck cuz her hair was always
down because you're always so in love
and then you're about to propose and she
puts her hair up and you just see a
little Raiders tattoo on the back of her
neck
that's
it no can't do it no and and not only
that I would have to publicly break up
with her I would have to publicly shame
her her I'm sorry I know it's terrible
but I I would have to and okay so I'm
now a Chiefs fan welcome what is a sport
that you weren't into maybe as until
recently any new ones um not oh pickle
ball I guess I never I never even knew
about pick I don't get it I think it's
done I'm good can we stop are we adults
it's it's sweeping the nation right now
no I don't good so it's like a wild so
was Co so have so is clamydia I'm not
doing this what is it are we so why are
we doing pickle I've never played I
don't even know the rules it's it's it's
tennis smaller with uh different you
know uh P it's like racket ball rackets
and and a and a whiffle ball but it what
happen what what it can do is it's got
everything covered it's got all four
quadrants as they like to say uhhuh old
young men women from child to the Grave
you can play this game and so it that's
a big net to cast okay sounds like
something for people with families godp
speed I'm so happy for all of you I
don't I play to win I'm not I don't want
to like I don't want to play some older
person but then you play someone your
age with the same Fitness level and you
smoke them and it feel good but why
don't we just their face take an Aderall
and play pool like
adults why do I have to play pickle ball
cuz you play 24 games a pool but isn't
it just cuz the name is funny I I I
thought the name actually does a
disservice to it you know I think it
actually detracts I don't need to learn
a new game at this point I'm I'm not
taking on new instructions so how are
you ever going to grow how are you ever
going to grow that fine I'll be just
fine I oh oh am I stunted by not
learning how to play pickle ball I'm
just say don't let it hold your back let
it hold back I just I feel like I'm
getting pressured and it's all of our
friends I'm not naming names Casey
Wilson June Rayfield Paul Shear I'm just
say it's all improv people that's the
other thing you know that it's all in
comedy improv people it's a lot of
improv people going to lie I'm not going
to lie it's literally I'm like I know
this is just so you guys can do bits
it's a lot of bits and I think I think
when it
started you know it's all bits it's all
bits and I don't I think Sports is
serious I don't I go to game night I
will I will lose a friend a 25 year
friend if they time time means time yeah
I don't care if you're working on your
new bit or standup routine pickle ball
for improvisor it has it it has a bevy
of bits you know how much attention do
you guys I think it started I think it
started with a yes and that went too
far I think it was what happened yeah
because this we gotta call it I'm the
person they asked me to do this improv
show in La once a really big one called
ascat and they tried to like loot me
standups and improvisors like I am so in
awe of improvisors because you that it's
it's just this freedom and flow that we
do not we don't play that shit if
something like I like the one time I did
an improv show at UCB afterwards I was
was like you guys you know that would
have been so much better if we just took
like 20 minutes and just like wrote
out I was like why don't we just write
next time why don't we write it first
and it's going to go really but you
can't do that see that's the and then
for askat one time they like threw some
you doing monologues or you actually
after doing scene work well I did some
scene work but like someone like threw a
ball at me and I like moved like to not
catch it like I I was like that's a good
move that's a good comedy move fun right
that's a good comedy move but then I
didn't go like pick it up I was just
like I'm not
like I was just like like I think I took
John Oliver we shared an office at The
Daily Show and I took him to ascat in
New York all the time but I I just made
him do monologues I didn't I was like
you don't have to play just do the
monologues you know and and he would
always do that and then he threw it back
at me and that's how I started doing
standup because he was like all right
now you're coming with me we're going to
go do standup I was like I can't fucking
do standup I suck I hate it they hate me
you know I would try to like beam things
to people if they were like hello and
welcome to the restaurant i' be like
no accent we don't don't do please don't
like I just found myself being like
trying to control it and write it with
them oh no yeah that's it takes time
though just like standup you know the
only way you get good at is stage time
and working and working it working cuz
i' I've gotten in lifeboats I'm like I'm
so glad we got in this Lifeboat we're
not in a Lifeboat and seen
everybody thank you so much lifebo this
is a Mercedes like I just I just so then
so then that was no butt
in that moment are you the crazy person
the schizophrenic patient apparently I'm
like H cuz really what do you do you
just in the scene there's nothing else
to do who do you think should host The
Daily Show as someone who's been on it
star um you know who I've enjoyed
watching thus far uh I thought Wanda
Sykes did a good job you know what my
number one draft pick is Wanda Sykes I
think Leslie Jones I love too but Wanda
Sykes to me is the funniest right now I
thought she'd be good also I thought she
had had the maturity the gravitas and
the the easygoing delivery yep that that
needs yes because you're there wasn't a
panic there wasn't a fuck you it wasn't
an aggression but it was this mature
level of hey man I've seen it all I've
been there I've done that and then
hilarious hilarious hilarious hilarious
and I I enjoyed sitting down to watch
that show it feels like you're like I
feel safe in your hands yeah yeah and
you're saying really terrifying
addressing really terrify scary stuff in
a way that's like really chill and not
making me panic exactly I I thought and
I've watched I haven't watched all of
the the you know guest host they've had
so there may be others y but uh I I
enjoyed her um so you are were merine
yes uh sorry to make this huge jump but
I I think a lot how much do you love
musical
theater like anybody else I guess I
really on three let's see how long you
can hold your breath and go I had a
child and it ate my entire brain do can
I get that cuz I'm trying to not drink
coffee where is our magic magic Minds
another one I've been I'm so obsessed
with these magic can I give me my magic
mind look at this okay this is my
totally my new obsession thank you Pat
oh it's I have another one right here I
need a magic mind in order to find my
magic mind that's standing right in
front of me so magic mine this is you've
had these right I'm obsessed with them
don't steal mine because this is the
only thing keeping me alive at this
point these are oh you just do the whole
thing it's a shooter it's a shooter you
just shot that whole thing is your
microphone faced away from you Pat I'm
not using the there's another one over
here I think we both need a couple magic
Minds today this is like the magic M
leading the magic mind um I've gotten so
obsessed with this for energy instead of
cuz here's the thing I can't take crazy
supplements anymore I can't take the
Ates I can't take the the eight Chan
Adderalls I was taking before just
kidding I get mine from a real doctor um
not taking anything for energy I'm not
even drinking coffee because my baby
does not respond well to my coffee
breath he's already
disgusted um magic mind is B it's like a
matcha tea what else is in here everyone
keeps asking me about it because
everyone's like how do you have so much
energy you just had a baby I'm like I do
these little shots called Magic mine
it has New Tropics matcha tea vitamins
for immunity adapt gens I'm just like
I'm over here on adaptogens what are you
up to y'all are just drinking coffee
like a bunch of
losers I shoot adaptogens all day I'm
obsessed with these cuz it's also it's
like you can't once you have a kid you
can't be a coffee person you can't be
carrying around a coughing mug I have SP
I within the first two days of having a
child I spilled hot coffee oh no on my
baby like TW and I was like okay this is
not going to work for many reasons you
just do one of these little Shooters
[Music]
boom God and it actually tastes
delicious I'm getting so much done with
these I basically just wake up in the
morning I do one of these I'll take a
nap like late afternoon and do one at
like 5: and I don't fall I don't um get
jittery like it gives you energy but
doesn't make you like a little psycho
you know like caffeine and all the don't
you think my energy is better yeah like
it's not like manic you're up in Adam
but you're calm and like focus and I
didn't just interrupt you I let you
finish talking I know wait Merry
Christmas to me thank you L Tada magic
mind magic mind helps you get ready to
achieve your New Year's goals for 2024
with full Focus this stuff is a game
changer magic mind.com Swit whne use my
code Whitney you're going to get 20% off
which is an extra 20% off which gets you
75% off lasts until the end of January
so hurry up so I with what is going on
in the world there's a war B and my
brain always goes to like oh God what if
there's like a
draft what would happen do you ever
think about that if we went back to a
draft 18 our 18-year-old boys oh and I
don't see gender sorry or girls or and
that's what they are they're boys still
I mean what are they going to do throw
Tide Pods at the end 26y olds that are
still boys we we have uh what's the plan
don't get me too hot on that one because
I will kind of lose it a little bit I I
don't have much faith in in lose it lose
it lose
it the the I find the younger generation
to be challenging um I think they're
incredibly smart and I think they have
uh they have all the capabilities that
any other generation does I just think
they have been uh a little bit pampered
yep a little they haven't been
challenged and they definitely can't
handle someone in their face and if you
can't handle someone in your face making
you uncomfortable yelling at you pushing
you beyond your whatever you think your
limits are you know uh you're not going
to make it in
war and you're going to Call of Duty
doesn't count exactly so it's a whole
different vibe it's a very different
Call of Duty and real dut to very
different Vibes so uh yeah no listen I
pray to God that we stay out of all the
troubles because I don't now the the the
the guys that are in there and the gals
that are in there we have a beautiful
volunteer Force they chose to be there
they wanted it great M but God forbid we
have to do anything long term or deep so
you raised a son yes well I'm in the
process yes and how did you navigate I'm
I'm I'm 50/50 sometimes I think I'm
killing it and the other times I can't
get his face out of that phone and it's
driving me nuts cuz the question is how
do we make sure that our our kids have
some adversity the way we had but also
I'm I'm about to have a son I I just
found out you can't pinch them anymore
you can't pinch kids that's how I got
through
church that's how my mom got me in and
out of groc sit I would sit there at
church and I'd be acting up of course
fussing with the in the Pew you know
doing bits grabbing the you know
grabbing the the song book whatever the
Himel whatever and I'd open it up and
try to find a funny title and then I'd
show everybody around me and then I'd
take the offering envelope and I would
do tic TCT toe and play with my sister
and my dad would just he would always
stare straight ahead and then ever so
slightly he'd Lan down and just pinch my
leg when I was getting two rambunctious
and I'd go Ow like out loud and I'd look
at him because and he wouldn't he would
never break he just stayed right
on he stayed right on the m and I so
everyone just thought that confused
they were like he's got a special need
and and cuz I I and I was always amazed
I was like why aren't you looking at me
like I just screamed you know like God
and then because this is how it works
though I started to figure out like oh
I'm I'm in trouble he's going to get me
afterward or whatever so I shut up and
i' sat down but it was just the you
yeah it was useful I mean I because I
remember I I didn't want to get in the
car and go to the grocery store I the
the ear would I'd be led into the
grocery store by the ear then I get in
the grocery store and if I didn't get
the cereal I wanted I would just sit on
the ground just sit on the ground you're
going to there's a consequence of that
like your mom would leave go to the next
stle until finally you're like oh God I
got to go I gotta but there was pinching
worked I don't think you can do that
anymore there's a lot of things that I'm
like I need to make sure I'm up to date
on what's illegal now so I had my son
last two week two weekends ago M and uh
I was invited to do this play reading up
in Santa Barbara right and so you know
I'm thinking I got my son for the
weekend he he'll love this no he won't
it's the worst thing play reading what
yeah it was a it was a it was a play
reading called war wordss and it was uh
anyway it was to help uh raise money for
hom was demilio there in it it was
homeless for homeless veterans and stuff
it was and so lovely about 10 actors
couple guys and gals that i' had worked
with in films and so I mean it was it
was a wonderful thing good event good
cause but I was like it was that moment
where I was like should I should I let
him off the hook should I say you know
you know you know spend the night with
or if you got friends and you want to do
something or you know get send them back
to his mom or what I was like no can I
ask how old he is 15 15 okay and I was
like no he's coming with me yep he's
coming with me and sometimes you just
got to do that with family I you know
how many times I went to my sister's
cheerleading camp or cheerleading this
hor or you know I mean it's one of those
things you're like oh my God it's your
family you just have to bite the bullet
a teenager also the same when people
like what's the point of school and yet
it's a lot of it is just learning to
tolerate discomfort and be patient and
do something you don't want to do yep
that's that's the adulting process is as
we know as adults now you do a lot of
what you don't want to do but you put a
smile on your face you done this today
and you are pulling it off as if you
actually want to be here and I'm buying
it I do want to be here but you're right
uh and so that that's part of the
process and you know it is uh uh Growing
Pains it's not growing easy it's it's
painful you know it's hard
responsibility accountability those
things suck what happened with the play
I'm on the edge of my seat oh nothing
you know he just was he had to come with
me and and he had to spend a lot of time
you know while I was doing the run
through and then the play reading and he
just had to sit out there and kind of
deal with it or whatever it wasn't
wasn't bad but it was that thing where
it's like you know and I even told him I
said look it might be a little boring
for you but feel free to you know Santa
barbar is a beautiful little town walk
around you know do some window shopping
get yourself a coffee way my parents
used to always say my aunt specifically
cuz I with my aunt um a lot of the time
and she would say go entertain yourself
yes and I like I'm bored boring people
are bored go entertain yourself I heard
so much and it it resonated even through
school even through my life I was like
you can do anything you want to me just
don't bore me and I'll self- entertain
yeah I don't care what it is i' I've
made up games where it's uh throwing
rocks into a be into a can from across
the street I'll do that for hours you
whatever it takes I'll Xerox I xeroxed
my face for like 3 hours a day when I
was a kid cuz my mom would take me to
work with her I would keep myself busy I
would Xerox my face and shoplift yeah I
think that's what boys and girls do
comedians I think that's what we do is
you especially if I'm around boring
people I will start to self- entertain
which means usually I start goofing I
start poking prodding you know agitating
anything I can to to get some play
there's a great book called hunt gather
parent and I just finished reading it
and it's about it's not your job to
entertain your kid so so many times
you're like I need to take you to the
escapades and I no it's like take the
kid to do all the boring things that you
have to do on a daily basis and it's
their job to be interest it's not your
job to be tap dancing and so I just went
and saw my daughter this weekend was
dad's weekend down at her college so I
went down we had a wonderful weekend
went to the football game you know just
hung out and you could have more adult
conversations stuff and I I was
reminiscing with her and I was like oh
do you remember this nope nope nope I
was like we spent thousands of dollars
on these like experiences and parties
and you know all this stuff nothing so
don't waste your money all they won't
remember shit
they don't remember anything under fifth
grade starting a fifth grade they start
to kind of VIP Disney pass you don't
remember how you remember cup 33 cost
thousands of dollars you don't remember
getting on the car's ride first you
don't remember not you don't remember
daddy standing in line while you and
everybody went and had fun you remember
daddy popping out into the alley to make
sure that we got those tickets uh so
that's so funny to me because when I I
see people be like Oh I'm taking my
5-year-old to Italy I'm like why take
take them to
majanos take them to Italy to Pizza Hut
take them to Pizza for CH sake are you
insane they're not going to remember any
of shit you're ruining so many people's
vacations yep you I couldn't agree more
everyone hates you yeah don't do
anything until they hit fifth grade when
they hit fifth grade they'll start to
have some memories it'll start to
connect at that point they'll start to
remember at that point and they that's
when they want to really go play and
have fun and enjoy themselves anything
else take them to the pool take them to
you know simple things simple things to
entertain they don't need give them a
tire and a hill yes that's we literally
it was go jump let's go jump off that
thing we go jump off things full day it
jump off the tractor jump off the
trailer put get in the tire roll down
the hill give him a sprinkler the the uh
the Fall Guy was a big show in the in
the early 80s uh it was like Lee Majors
and he was a stunt man right and so all
my friends we were like well we're
stuntmen too so we would go get the
cushions off the like the L the lawn
chairs or whatever they're like they're
thin as this table and and we' go we'd
set like two of them and we jump off the
roof onto as our Crash Pad we would do
it with an
umbrella cuz that's GNA we saw Mary
Poppins we like oh we can jump off roofs
with umbrellas I it slow us yeah yeah
and then the key is let your kid get
injured so then they'll be in a cast for
6 months that's your only hope of having
a break then they're on the couch you're
golden I have this and they've learned a
valuable lesson when is the last time
you saw a child in a cast oh my God it
like doesn't even happen no because the
uh the hovering the protection do you
remember we had aast you coddle if you
coddle your child through their I read
this great article it's called let him
climb the tree o and what it talks about
is if you don't let your child climb the
tree they will never learn or
respect um gravity injury m or risk and
they become risk averse because they
don't understand risk and that's why you
have the highest killer of teenagers is
reckless driving whoa reckless driving
for teenage boys and the reason is is
because they don't understand risk they
don't understand it because they never
got to climb the tree when you climb the
tree you learn you get up there and
you're like oh I'm too high I'm coming
back down or you fall or you you know
you you just get a perspective right and
and we get hurt now yes we don't let
them climb the tree Stakes being low
instead of when you're going 80 miles
hour because when you learn early that
there's risk to we used to build ramps
and jump our bikes over the ramps and do
something and of course you know people
would get hurt people break their ankles
break their wrists do you remember
slipping slides of course we would just
throw hurl ourselves yes at 100 miles
hour we used to put Palm Olive on it oh
yeah oh even yeah even dawn we used
Dawn and we and you would like slick as
snot I mean yeah and then You' go off
think maybe we should take the rocks out
from underneath and you'd hit the grass
I'd have grass Burns do you remember the
flexible flyer sled yes that was it had
two like it was like a a railroad track
it was two metal bars and we used to do
Chinese downhills that's what it was
called back then I you know offends
anybody it was called a Chinese downhill
and it was where everybody started real
estate in
America and spread of virus from lab Lab
uh we uh uh everybody would run so you
have like 12 to 15 kids running with
their SL and they all start at the same
time and as you went down it was a
massive you're trying to flip everybody
knock everybody off you're running into
each other and people were just like end
overend cartwheel it was a melee and
everybody get to the bottom and whoever
was you know one one and and then
everybody reminisce about the story go
back up and do it again now that those
kids gotten died in car accidents later
that's right know what I mean that's
right we crashed him but we didn't die
that is so fascinating like cuz uh uh
you know I remember my dad always had
this theory he was like I'd rather you
get learn in here than out there yeah
you know my mom went time I've told the
story before but she slapped me across
the face when I was 11 years old I said
something that I should not have said to
her and she smacked me across the face
and I I was as I was hitting the wall I
was so grateful cuz like I would have
done that at somewhere else and it would
have been way worse you know it's our
job to be harder on our kids a little
bit well that's what I wrestle with with
with my boy and he's fine you know he's
a good he's a very he's a wonderful
child but I do you know I think our we
have to uh make them resilient we have
to give them that resiliency we have to
because they're going everybody's going
to hit adversity we're all going to hit
it everybody does there's no way to
avoid it nobody gets out here born kids
also when you give a kid a warning this
is dangerous it just makes them more
like when you're like don't touch the
light socket you're like well now I got
to go touch put my finger in the light
socket yeah why not now you just I
wouldn't even have thought to put my
finger in that before that's a human
thing too I think if says don't do that
yes you're like why not and if they
can't give you satisfactory answer
you're like well I need to find out for
myself and when I go with my friends to
the um playgrounds now which by the way
are all made of plastic our and they're
on like a mushy yeah uh they cut up
tires they shred tires so it's a big
it's a rubbery foamy cushy thing ours
was like a asphalt asph gravel and
little pieces of gravel like on top and
steel remember rusted steel it was
scaffolding there was like a there was a
what was the monkey bars was just
scaffolding it was scaffolding and with
edges and do you remember the chain link
pirate chain you would just climb a
rusty chain yeah I also remember the
bigger kids that would be like what are
you doing they muscle you the bullies
and you'd have to deal you had to
negotiate that yep yep yep and what what
that meant was we'd ride our bikes up
there the older kids were there we come
back later that's you just you learn how
to make choices
you know we're going to go over there
and go we're here to play too no no no
no no you're going to get an ass
whooping remember the everything was so
rickety the merry go around was always
so rickety the and janky it was always
off-kilter always and someone always
just like I was like you're like where
did Jimmy go just underneath and then um
there was just so much scary shit but I
see my girlfriends with their kids and
they're like be careful don't get on
that and be careful that's dangerous and
that's and it's just like it's a
disservice I see the kid looking at
their parents like why did you bring me
here if it's so d i play now I'm
confused and they're just in this
general anxiety instead of let them go
let them go and then when they're
actually in some kind of danger that's
when you intervene right of course
you're not going to sit no one's going
to sit there and allow the child to be
hurt but let them let them run a muck
and when they bang their head they're
going to come to you crying and guess
what they may have a little knot on
their head you you rub it you love them
up and then you let them play again and
guess what they're going to figure this
stuff out and they're going to be okay
but if you deny them the opportunity to
climb that tree you're setting up a
teenage bomb advice for raising a boy
advice for raising a boy uh you got to
let him be a boy you know what that's
the big one you don't always stop them
like boys are rambunctious boys are
mischievous I'll never forget the day my
son walked out of the his bedroom he was
probably four and he goes what is this
or what is this made out of and I was
like metal it was some metal part to a
like it looked like a hinge and and I I
go it's metal he goes why I said and I
said why why he goes cuz I can't break
it and then he went back in his
room that's just I was like oh that's
the that's what's up today that's the
reason why I need to figure out why I
can't break something yeah he came back
what is this what's this made out of
metal I said why son he's like I can't
break it and he was frustrated and he
went back in this is what happens with
boys they picked stuff up and they're
like huh he took a bite out of a club
cracker one time and it gripped it like
a gun and was just doing this and he was
four years old like he hadn't been
exposed to like Rambo movies or Call of
Duty he just instinctively bit into a
cracker and it kind of had a shape and
he started shooting people with his Club
cracker this is the stuff that happens
with boys so you know don't panic don't
freak out like I gave birth to a school
shooter exactly but you know and when
they're rambunctious you know it it
takes it you know you have to let them
but at the same time you kind of have to
get them how did the birds in the Taco
with your
son so good yeah nailed it it think I
nailed it pretty sure I nailed it did
you have to have like a formal I I had a
I had a a uh I did have a talk I did uh
with him I feel like it was this exact
energy I did um no eye contact was made
I looked down L of the ceiling the
floor and then when I finish the
statement I go we good and then I was
out we're cool
homie uh no all but uh his generation is
obviously much different than mine I all
I said was you know obviously uh if you
have any question a box uh under uh the
car we don't use in the garage please
take a look take your
time lock the door your mother won't be
home till L get in and out leave
everything as you found it give yourself
about a 15-minute cush trust me on that
one oh god um but I I had to talk to him
about um you know
porn that's the birds and the bees talk
these days it is it's different uh it's
a that's why I say it's a different
generation meaning look I said you know
I didn't think that I didn't know what
you meant by that I was like cuz there's
no pubes now well I said I said there's
nothing you can ever tell me or say to
me that I don't know I've heard it all
seen it well I never say seen it all but
I said I've heard it all I've been
exposed to it all there's nothing you're
ever going to bring to me that's going
to shock me or make me offended or
there's just nothing that is off limits
so first of all any question and I'm
talking about you know if you want to
even talk about how do you kiss or make
out or what I'll go down I'll go down
those roads with you I'm not going to do
it now but I want you you put on that
helmet you go to the VR simulation and
you ask the bot for permission that's
how the kids do it these
days you go to the back of La weekly
call the 1800 number I opened the door
and just let him know that there nothing
was off limits it was totally safe all
that stuff but I did say you are going
to be bombarded with uh stuff that I was
never B if I wanted private time as I
like to call it yeah um back in the day
it was Sports Illustrated that was that
was my private time yeah okay their
private time you know you've seen the
internet I don't have to describe what's
on there it's horrific far as the
options and the choices and the things
and the so and it comes out of it comes
out of nowhere and the thing is is he's
a good boy but you know he goes over to
friends house who have older
brothers what you can't control
everything you just can't and so you
just try to educate him that there are
things out there you know and you may
see things or hear things you know I
heard you know things that didn't make
any sense and I I wish I would have had
to I always had to go to my either my
sister's boyfriend or somebody that I
could go to and be like so what does
this mean because I remember seeing in
the movie risky business he's like
buffing and fucking were two different
things or whatever
and I thought they were the same thing
or remember that movie buffing is
fucking or something oh I didn't yeah so
I thought I thought I metant buff
fucking and I don't know you know like I
just didn't know things don't ask girl
to you don't know things when you're
young and when someone says oh you
jerked off you're like yeah what
especially when you're super young you
just don't know all the nomenclature and
stuff so I said just come to me and I
will explain everything I can and if you
see or hear something that shocks you
and it confuses you just come to me and
ask just send it to me I'll save it on
on my phone I'll watch it as many times
as I need to in order to a thorough
review and I'll get back to you maybe
I'll I'll explore all the rest of her
work to make sure she's someone worth
investing I don't know she's credible
yeah it's a good source good source
material I do my own research in this
house we do our own research okay that's
so fascinating to me there is a a great
talk um uh by Gail d d n e it's a TED
Talk and it's about how you know boys
look when you're 12 13 you want to see
booby
and you should be able to see boobies
you know the comedian Dan
mince stand up he um has this great joke
he's very like dry onliners and he goes
you know growing like things are so
different now with watching porn like
when I was you know a kid I had to wait
for the Sears catalog to come and then I
have to flip to the lingerie section but
this day and age I can just go to
sears.com that's great that's a good one
it's such a good job that's a good one
you know but it's like every 13 boy
should be able to go see see boobies but
if you go Google
boobies crazy stuff comes up that they
no one should ever have to see it
escalates quickly and escalates to
Google sex or something and then you
think that's what sex is that's not what
sex is I have a a girlfriend whose
daughter was I want to say 16 or she had
her first kind of it wasn't sex but
sexual experience with a boy and gets
whatever version of you know and the boy
was like horrified in of what he saw and
accidentally kind of shamed her and
because he had never seen
pubes because if you've only seen porn
you would never these days you wouldn't
even have known that that was a thing so
she was like am I weird and oh yeah and
there's so much confus but let's be
honest if everybody went back and
thought genuinely about your first
sexual encounters whatever it was a
makeout session or actual sex or being
felt up or groping or whatever it was it
was all uncomfortable it was all awkward
it was all Uncharted water it was all
confusing yeah we had braces half of us
got tness right and then after you did
the groping or the make out or the you
know whatever you would Retreat back to
your friend group and say this is what
happened was that am I am I in the
ballpark here that is that what's yeah I
made out you stick your tongue in the
mouth yeah you know and they go okay
good you know don't stick too far you're
like yeah course but you have to now I
think you have to consent on an app
first I mean there's a lot of but it's
about that bad but but that's how it
worked you had to you it was a it was an
awkward thing that you had to discover
as you went and you just hoped that you
were in a friend group or a peer group
that had the kind of the same values the
kind of the same you know respectability
you know that you were like he's a good
guy or she's a good person or whatever
and so that's you gravitated towards
each other and you were kind to one
another and you tried to do it the right
way yeah you know but that's the best
you could hope for yeah and it's I think
it's still true but I don't know because
it's hilarious I watched my my daughter
go through high school and I they no
date I I used to have a girlfriend like
in my freshman year all the way through
my senior year like we had and we go
date night I know but now nobody dates
nobody cares there's no boyfriend
girlfriend thing and I'm like well was I
know I was crazy horny in high school
are any you know I don't want to ask but
are they not they're not it's their uh
the age that um kids are losing their
virginity is going up it's getting very
very high the age that people are having
girlfriend boy they kind of like text
constantly they'll just like constantly
text with each other and Snapchat with
each other and instead of getting
together they're not down for the
private time I think the if you're a boy
who can do the private time whenever
with your computer or your phone you
know and it's a sure thing beautiful
women yeah yeah it's or just many
different
scenarios and then it's sort of like oh
I'm now I've seen this so I don't know
how to do that so now I'm insecure I
think you're right am I expected to do
that yeah you know and I think that that
boys probably see it more as like
research like I want to learn how to do
this thing and then it it's probably
even more I mean imagine like in our day
like it was just like awkward and clumsy
imagine right now a guy grabbing your
hair you be like what are you doing like
where did that come from you know I
think there's a lot of that just like
confusion if you've been watching porn
first I would agree you know I would
agree and so that was our birds and bees
talk it was a lot of uh there's a ton
out there come to me when you are
confused and you will be I think that's
a big thing is making sure that your
kids don't keep secrets from you boy
right and there's there to it's age
appropriate to carve out your own
identity it's age appropriate to seek
Independence and push against the
boundaries and as a parent you kind of
have to give them room as they grow
right but so I I expect a little bit of
that so some Secrets I expect I kept
secrets from my dad uhhuh you know like
smoking a cigarette on Friday night you
know God like I want to do Improv
but I promise I'll be a marine first
yeah exactly I I totally want to life in
the theater but I'll be hug
first let me ask you you seem like a
nightmare for a the boy that wants to
date your daughter I would not I'd be
scared to meet you I'm so that's
hilarious I'm like overly gracious like
I try so hard to be I really I it's it's
how you know how to win friends and
influence people chapter by chapter I'm
like smiling I'm you know I'm I'm I'm
asking questions I'm trying to be
engaging and interested and you know
what do you make of the boys that you
know she went to prom with and stuff
were you like was that kind of nice boys
very nice uh they seem kind of dorky
these days they they're just you know
what it is they they didn't have to do
what we did which was talk to
people face to face look them in the eye
how are are you today make conversation
what's Small Talk they don't know what
small talk is no um and they also don't
understand the art of conversation which
is Small Talk they're like small FS we
share we share you know you tell me a
little bit little awkward you tell me a
story I'll tell you a story you tell me
what you're doing I'll tell you what I'm
doing oh I have a friend who does what
you're doing tell me more about that
they don't understand that
it's what do you do I like this I like
this I like this and I do this and then
and and then they'll talk about
themselves all day and then they go then
they shut down and you're like it's not
a back and forth yeah it's not all it's
do you want to tell me all about you
knock yourself out now this this isn't
the case with the boys that my daughter
brought home they were just in general
they were good but just in general I see
it with among young men um it's it's
they don't understand the art of
conversation conversation that's so
interesting yeah it's died and um uh and
you know it's because they don't have to
yep when I call my daughter she thinks
it's an emergency like all of you guys
are think you're going to have podcasts
as a career godp speed on that yeah
knock yourself out we'll see how that
goes yeah right good luck with that hey
y'all Did You Know 35% of all fatal
accidents occur between 6 p.m. and
midnight and that people age 25 to 34
have the highest amount of drivers
involved in car crashes and that people
aged 15 to 24 had the highest rate of
emergency room visits due to car
accidents of all age groups also did you
know that vultures could help solve
crimes I just wanted to throw that in
there Morgan and Morgan
I love talking about how vultures can if
you guys want to use that fact in your
investigations go for it anyway if
you've ever been injured you can check
out Morgan and Morgan as someone who
just gave birth to a child I wanted to
call Morgan and Morgan and hire them to
sue my baby for me because child birth
is a scam I was conned and I would like
to sue my child for damages look child
birth is hard hiring Morgan and Morgan
is easy Morgan and Morgan is America's
largest injury Law Firm they have over
100 offices Nationwide and more than 800
lawyers with over1 15
billion recovered for over 3,000 clients
Morgan and Morgan has a proven track
record of fighting to get you full and
fair compensation Morgan and Morgan has
been fighting for the people for over 35
years submitting an injury claim with
Morgan and Morgan is so easy okay
crowning is hard submitting an injury
claim with Morgan and Morgan is easy if
you're ever injured you can check out
Morgan and Morgan their fee is free
unless they win for more information go
to forth people.com Whitney or dial
pound law pound 529 from your cell phone
that's
forthepeople.com Whitney or pound law
pound 529 from your cell phone this is a
paid advertisement let me tell you a
story about when I started podcasting
because back then an online
store could wasn't even in my purview
okay it was the furthest thing from my
tiny little lady brain all right the
lady brain that wrote the book that I am
now selling see it behind me see how
good I am at marketing why can't I there
we go see it right behind me yes I wrote
a book it's called I'm fine in other
lies and it is fine and it's also so
easy to sell because I use Shopify and
look here's what I will say it's way
easier to use Shopify than it is to read
an ad about
Shopify as you can tell by me bumbling
trying to get this right Shopify I can
get this right is the global Commerce
platform that helps you sell at every
stage of your business from the launch
your online shop stage to the first real
life store stage all the way to the did
we just hit a million order stage can't
wait to get there Shopify is there to
help you grow whether you're selling
scented soap or off making custom baby
outfits out of baloney Shopify helps you
sell every it's not a bad idea now that
I have tried to feed myself and and
dress a baby
simultaneously if there was a okay just
Quick Pitch baby outfits made of
baloney cuz sometimes when you put a
onesie on a baby which is the definition
of insanity trying to get not a onesie
like a long sleeve thing and trying to
get their little hands through the tiny
little holes if I could just nibble off
trim it trim it and get a snack
simultaneously edible underwear no
edible baby outfits yeah you can go from
long pants to shorts long pants to short
that's what I'm saying or who's in know
someone call Shark Tank Shopify call me
let's do a collab you can sell
everywhere with Shopify from their
all-in-one e-commerce platform to their
in-person POS system wherever and
whatever you are selling shopify's got
you covered Shopify helps you turn
browsers into buyers with the internet's
best converting checkout 36% better on
average compared to other leading
Commerce platforms and sell more with
less yes I did just hit my face in the
microphone that was wild so if only it
was made of baloney if only it was made
of baloney we wouldn't be in this
Jam that was crazy I
just can we all start selling
microphones that beep when you start to
deepthroat them during an ad and sell
more with less effort thanks to Shopify
magic your AI powered Allstar they show
you who abandoned a checkout and this is
amazing so they'll show you who abandon
a checkout and you can act on it right
so I can be like hey I see that you
added this product to your cart and then
forgot about it do you want me to send
someone over to your house to press buy
now what happened did you fall asleep at
the wheel did you have second thoughts
you could rethink your whole strategy
based on the analytics that Shopify
gives you they give you Intel okay they
give you hot Intel that's their motto
Intel Intel Intel because number one
advice in selling know your customer I
don't know if that's the number one
advice but it feel feels like it's up
there and I feel like I know what I'm
talking about Shopify it Powers 10% of
all e-commerce in the US and Shopify is
the global force behind all birds rothis
Brooklyn and and millions of other
entrepreneurs of every size across 175
countries I didn't even know there were
that many countries plus Shopify they
have award-winning help they're to
support your success every step of the
way because businesses that
grow grow a Shopify and yes I did just
do an air gun sign up for a $1 per month
trial period at shopify.com
Whitney all lowercase go to shopify.com
Whitney now to grow your business no
matter what stage you're in shopify.com
Witney a
chaing do you have big H do holiday
stuff I'm way behind the curve I got to
get up Christmas lights I guess yeah we
got to get going on the Christmas light
but I also like to keep them up full
into like February too I keep them up
till January 8th I because that's
Elvis's birthday is it and that's what
Elvis used to do do you love Elvis I
love Elvis so basically what happens he
used to put his Christmas lights up you
kind of when you talk about him you talk
more like him too I don't think I
[Applause]
do I don't
notice immediately but
um Friday after Thanksgiving lights go
up and then on January 8th which is his
birthday he took him down so I was like
that's my model that's how I do it now
have you heard the conspiracy theory
that he died and they replaced him with
someone else
no I've heard the conspiracy the that he
was still alive and the fact that they
misspelled his name on his grave on his
on his Stone his Tombstone was an
indicator that he's still alive because
he was like ah see it's not official
because they misspelled his name how do
you misspell Elvis's name right because
if they put Aaron his middle name is
Aaron and they put uh which is AA a lot
of people spell it AA a
Aon yes okay right uh but that's not how
he spelled it I think and so I'm like
you're telling me this multi-billionaire
a guy who still makes $50 million a year
on his name they couldn't fix it at
graceand uhuh that's a bullshit marker
so what is what is it but who did it I
don't know why would they do that so
that he could live in the
woods and party and just be Elvis man
he's fishing right
now so you're telling me that he told
the
coroner hey
I'm going to fake my death yep and I'm
going to need you and and the way I'd
like to go down in history is that I
died of constipation no now that's where
things got squirly that's where it got
off the rails don't you think he would
have picked a cooler death if he was
going to fake it apparently Chuck Norris
was banging Priscilla at the time oh and
uh Elvis and Chuck were karate
Rivals now I again I can't prove any of
this but I think we're close I think
feel I got a pretty good idea so you're
here telling me that he went I need you
to misspell my name I missell my name
that makes it all bullshit yeah like did
he talk like that when he wasn't out
like when he was just talking normal no
yeah had a real uh like a Jersey accent
I feel like it would have taken forever
to do anything if he just like him just
in the
wild put this on what I I'm going to
need you to can you stop talking like
Elvis for a minute understand like I
feel like he had two voices like much
blew me a kiss and he was gone I'm
confused but so because that's the thing
about some of these conspiracy theories
I'm like I just think people are so
inherently um riddled with snitch energy
like someone would have had to be like
okay I know the deal you can't keep a
secret between two or three people
you're going to tell me hundreds of
people for dozens and of decades didn't
say shit someone a lot of people would
have had to keep this Secret for ye for
decades uhhuh uhhuh and and it would
have to be ongoing it's not a it's not a
lie that you forget it's a sustaining
lie you know like give me a it's not
like oh wait I forgot I helped Elvis
fake his death I keep forgetting you
know and and it's one of those things to
I I have I have some friends that have
suffered terribly in my opinion with the
conspiracy stuff with the kunan with the
you know they they've they've they
bought into it then they drill down on
it then they feed themselves the steady
diet of conspiracy and they they've lost
themselves and it's sad I truly it's
heartbreaking yeah because they you know
and you want to sit down and goes okay
over the last 10 years since you've
adopted this show me all the things that
have come to fruition that be happy to
so let me just pull up this folder I
have I would love to show you all the
reasons you're wrong about my religion
you're coming you're coming for my
happiness and safe place and frankly
you're challenging truth um no when it
comes to some stuff like we had the
actress Taran Manning on you know her
and she sort
of alluded to Hollywood's like
Illuminati what would you call it pat
like like a grand conspiracy of
entertainment and the she said like I
got offered the go to drink the gold
juice you know kind of something and she
didn't take it and she didn't take it
and I in my head I thought she was like
it was like a metaphor for something
thing why haven't I been offered the
gold juice that's what I said yeah
because we're scumbag Comics we don't if
you're after scale they don't they don't
they're not interested in giving you
anything you five under five lines yeah
you you have to bring b y OJ have to
bring your own juice to set no one word
loud mouths no one would ever I everyone
knows I can't keep a secret so um they
uh so and then like it got really viral
on on Tik Tok and stuff and so many
people were like well that's
adrenochrome that's when they take
babies and shot and take blood from
babies and that kind of oh God I heard
that yeah apparently well I won't
mention any names but yeah yeah I've
heard this that that to me that's too
far well that's why I say like I I am
not a conspiracy theorist and I don't
buy into the craziness if I can ask
decent questions and the answers are
painfully obvious however I do think
people conspire I think people do evil
shit yep so it's not it's not that I
don't believe in conspiracies I just
don't think everything's a fucking
conspiracy sometimes things just up one
thing that I um uh Putin I I CU I didn't
really understand his like appeal and
charm and I guess I don't know I'm just
the reason we get obsessed with these
dictators and totalitarians and you're
like how do they pull this off you know
and someone asked him about the Ukraine
and he was it's a video online and
someone goes like why are you invading
the why are you doing this and he just
went they're a bunch of drug
addicts and and that's his that was it
and it was so gangster it was so
dismissive it was so how do you argue
with that it was so simple shallow and
so not stately that's not what a head of
state says not what a reason in if I was
I get I kind of been like well yeah I
mean it's so
rude it's so
disrespectful it's just so and I kind of
believed him when he said it and I was
like this is so manipulative and genius
and he's not like well and we need to do
that he was like there're a bunch of
drag addicts and I was like I like
believed him I was like yeah that sounds
wait what like there was no speech per
he just it was the West I'm not trying
too hard I'm me and why would you say
that if it wasn't true right well he's
he's all he's uh got a deliver he's very
nonchalant that's what it is he's very
nonchalant in his deliveries so you're
like it's very simple and and he's so
confident and his nonchalantness that
you go well yeah that I don't see he's
not having a f must true because if he
was like well they do drugs you'd be
like I feel like you're projecting a
little bit but it was just so resigned
to it and like we got to handle these
drug addicts and then another one he was
like well they're a bunch of Nazis and
never forget though that he spent his
formative
years deep in the KGB KGB yeah deep in
the KGB and and the West United States
specifically but the West is a mortal
enemy that he grew up thinking about
fighting and and destroying and you know
because that was the mindset like we
beat them in hockey once and they lost
their shit lost their shit um but so his
mindset you know and then when when the
Soviet Union collapsed you know it
caused a lot of national um
embarrassment National shame National
you know they had to find their identity
again it's it's like after World War I
when Germany was punished so hard for
the loss of the war they were shamed
they were they were you know they were
they became these uh
you know and and what did that do it
made them all Circle their wagons and
say no we Germans are good they didn't
have National they didn't have pride and
Hitler came in and said let have pride
when the Soviet Union collapsed that's a
proud Nation a world leader there were
two superpowers and one of them just
collapsed right and then and then after
it collapsed the 90s were just them
selling off their Navy and their army
and their guns and there was Warlords
and there was O archs and it was just a
shit show right because it was the old
west well now there's this national
pride and there's one leader it's you
know it's the scary the parallels can be
very intimidating and they control the
news in a way that the people that live
there they don't even you know you
control what the people see hear read
think you can control my friends that
are Russian are like I love that you
guys just found out about fake news cuz
we're like this news is fake they're
like that's the only news we've ever
read it's just it's all propaganda yeah
you know and let me ask you one that
kind of makes me laugh though because I
find myself saying it where I'm like oh
well we got to be careful you know
people there's rumors that Putin has
cancer he's dying or what'll happen like
you know what if he presses the nuke
button like it's not a
button right it's not like a big red
Looney Tune they follow around yeah big
yeah they do have they do have the
codes they do have the codes but don't
you think that it's called the nuclear
football and you'll always see there's
somebody around the president in the
United States at all times with the
nuclear football and all that means is
that's true yeah wherever wherever the
president is he has the ability to
initiate or to defend an attack so if
North Kore
nukes Hawaii right he can go into the
code book and read off the codes and go
through the proper channels they have
checks and balances but they that's why
you have the nuclear football following
the president everywhere he goes day and
night and it's handcuffed to uh military
attache and uht honest the reason this
is making me laugh is just because I
love that humans are just so human like
i' love the guy who you know has the co
has it handcuffed to him
how do you get that job like the guy
who's like fucking hell man like how did
I it was all because fucking Tony back
in 1947 left the briefcase
somewhere why does it have to be handc I
mean it's Tony dickhead Tony they were
like Tony where's the briefcase he's
like oh I left it in the diner they're
like fucking handcuff it Tony so every
morning like we're do I have to yes Tony
you do so he goes to the back when he
goes to the bathroom he's got the
brief
yeah all because some dickhead back in
the day hold on left it I mean so does
it's just like a does it when they
switch shifts is it like
yeah an eight hour shift I'm assuming mm
yeah I there's like what if you like
meet a girl and like on your break oh
but you're not on a break you're right
by the present okay you're just holding
the briefcase you're sitting there like
this but how do you get that job is it
it's a military you're in the military
you're either Air Force Navy or I feel
like it's you appointed because if it's
a job you want it's not a job they
should let you have right I think they
they have all kinds of attaches assigned
to the White House he is the
commander-in chief so he's got to be
able to communicate so he's got a staff
of but since we haven't it's the kind of
thing where it's like you know you got
to start a car a vintage car you know
once a month so that when you do start
it at works like yeah do they have
drills all the time okay they have
drills they have to go around and make
sure I'm obsessed that like we need the
new codes are like oh we never we didn't
we weren codes C codes codes go you Bob
you had I did I did there was a software
update did I in the the plug did is it
plugged in okay where are they they're
downloading sir download hold on one
second I just I'm getting the spinny
wheel I'm getting are you on Wi-Fi I
just can we can dropped Wii so I can get
on you have a Samsung you can't have a
Sam you've got the codes on a it's the
my bubbles green like I just feel like
there's going to be a logistical glitch
no they they they have worked this out
sadly over the last 60 years um to
include the Cuban Missile Crisis and
that's where that's where the red phones
came from so that we wouldn't have
nuclear war because what happened was
they were uh there was a confusion heads
of state couldn't talk to one another so
after the Cuban Missile Crisis they
installed a red phone in the Oval Office
and at the Kremlin so that the president
could pick up and say and they would
know it's coming from it was only
connected through the White House cuz
otherwise you could do deception plans
you did they update the phone or is it
still like a cartoon landline it's a
landline it's a cartoon red phone
everything yeah still still but what if
it
like is bad you know what I mean I feel
like if they need to use it like why
haven't we updated the phone it's been
40 years yeah you need face FaceTime me
yeah totally like I well now they do I
think now they actually do FaceTime okay
because uh like I'm you do a decep you
could do a deception type thing on with
the phones yeah you know you get a sound
alike you get you know someone out
meanwhile they're launching the missiles
so they can get you first uh you know
there's some weird stuff but that all
that's not going to happen but they do
they have to they they do maintenance on
the missiles every you know every week
okay see that's what iOS yeah they keep
them fueled they keep them all the parts
working they'd have to take them out
repair them put them back we're sure oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah I don't know what
spookier the fact that it is always they
are always being made but how do they
know they're going to work uh because we
do constant testing okay constant
testing and constant updating and
sometimes if the if the missile's old
you take it out and you put in a new one
and you scrap the old one was it in
Russia when they were doing a lot of
those in the 90s or maybe it was more
during the Cold War sorry was earlier
than that um a lot of the tanks were
like cardboard like a lot of they well
in World War III they did that yeah yeah
was they a whole fake Army yeah in
England to to trick the Germans I'm
obsessed with that yeah like the person
who had to set up the fake who's
building the cardboard yeah and they
were they were Inflatables they were
inflatable tanks so they when Germans
flew over they'd be like they've got
10,000 tanks and they were just they
were inflatabl that's why I'm curious
like how much of this is
just well we we our satellites are so
good there's and so are theirs our
adversaries are China and Russia they're
they Park their satellites over the top
of the United States in geosync uh so as
the United States spins their satellites
just hover over us so they're watching
us 24/7 we're doing the same to them and
and we can we can see missiles coming
and going do you think that's what the
alien spotting sometimes might be yes
which by the way that's the story of the
freaking Century that no one gives two
shits about no one cares like it's like
shiny Keys over here meanwhile aliens
Landing UFOs we've acknowledged them now
you know it's all good I have a theory
because that no one wants to to um uh
pay the like pay wall like I literally
would go to like the Wall Street Journal
it'd be like are do we have aliens it'
be like $2.99 like I'm not going to put
it my credit someone will tell me about
it you know about it I don't know if I
bought it I I believe aliens are out
there somewhere I don't think those when
you see flying saucers and stuff do you
think some of that is other countries
surveillance and satellites and stuff
yes I think I think uh um uh I I don't
know I think there's UFOs unidentified
flying objects yes for sure we've got
the we got the proof but I don't know I
haven't seen an alien yet yeah no one's
part no one's made contact no there
haven't been any conversations there
haven't been any handshakes so until
that happens come on I it's interesting
there was um I think it was in the
Atlantic an article about how um
basically we get our ideas from it's
actually us it's actually people that
write movies and make movies like we
decided they were going to be green and
look the way they look so that's what
we're looking for but if you're like a
an advanced extraterrestrial your
spaceship is going to just look like an
airplane yeah or a crow well and if you
also if you think people wouldn't lie
about this I'm like guys people have all
kinds of motives for doing what they do
I watched an interview of a man being
interviewed who had had alien contact
okay this was shot in the 1950s okay and
he was like he's like he was a it was it
was a genuine news report so he's this
man's out there and he's like can you
tell me what you experienced well they
were just like us they came off and he
said his name was you know x-ray 10,000
and he was a nice man we shook hands he
walked around I explained the crops that
I was growing he said thank you and he
got back so he spoke English he was a
homo sapien sure you know and he got
back on his spacecraft after having a
pleasant conversation with you and just
departed okay like I'm sorry I don't
believe that also it's like why are all
they all naked it seems like I feel like
they would have figured out clothes if
they could figure out how to move that
fast they would have figured out how to
disguise themselves as clouds or
something that we see anyway all the
time I think they're not going to look
like what we think they're going to look
like they probably look either so human
that we would never know they weren't or
Not Human at all I feel like right I
think a lot of it beyond our beyond our
conception I they're going to be like
we're not going to look like the weird
puppet that was in ight Shyamalan signs
we're not doing that and just this this
solar system alone what I don't listen
also you can spend you can spend all
your time overthinking this shit I would
love to or yes please with the life add
to cart no thank you add to
cart I would yeah I I reject
that you're the best oh thanks for
having me wriggles pick podcast Sports
it's coming it's happening and
interviews and interviews Travis Kelsey
out of the gates I mean come on that's
the guy that's the guy my goodness yeah
I and welcome to Chief station thank you
I'm ready to I can't am I no but we
can't wear the he feather uh no no no
headdresses okay we have an arrowhead
okay like like um Steve
Martin like just a wacky arrow through
the head classic I want that's that's
going to be your
signature classic comedy bit oh me
offensive what I'm going to go down to
the magic shop anything else anything
else we're allowed to talk about movies
and promote stuff now I know uh always
in everything I'm going to shoot a
little movie uh down in Alabama in
January very excited
nice we're back and like everything else
you know we're just out there always be
developing ABD every day we hustle in
never ends you know how we do I do I
think it's so embarrassing to have to
promote uh television these days because
the names of networks have gotten so I'm
check me out on voodo I mean you
literally have to see Ryan Gosling like
I have a new show on ho the HOA Network
you're like oh God can we we used to
call them the N the National
Broadcasting Company the a ABC now so
simple it just NBC was like got it got
it free what how what what did you just
say to me I'm on bantamweight I'm sorry
bant is that a new I don't have is that
a platform so and it sounds like it's
like so so everything you just have to
make guttural noises at this I'm on Hulu
Voodoo ciso like just can we get a word
in one of these networks and it's like
my new to show on Amazon the grocery
store we're doing TV for grocery stores
now I mean the whole thing is just it's
so hard to have any
it's you know it is it really is that
got so real I'm sorry I'm sorry I love
you I end these very awkwardly the great
Rob wriggle don't ride elephants I love
[Music]
you
and